spätestens seit der industrialisierung
optimieren wir uns menschen durch technik und wissenschaft immer wieder geht es ja hier bei uns um cyborgs also
mischwesen aus mensch und maschine und ich wette es dauert nicht mehr lange bis wir alle einen röntgenblick haben oder eine ähnliche
bahnbrechende optimierung solch eine künstliche erweiterung des menschen wird auch human enhancement
genannt ihr habt euch dieses thema bei whatsapp gewünscht und bekommt jetzt alle wichtigen facts dazu was ist bereits heute möglich
und was ist für die nahe zukunft geplant und werden wir menschen bald
unsterblich jetzt in klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
das, thema human enhancement also die künstliche verbesserung des menschen lässt sich in drei bereiche aufteilen schon längst erweitern wir den menschlichen körper
mechanisch also beispielsweise durch prothesen oder
herzschrittmacher zur leistungssteigerung nutzen wir medizinische hilfsmittel und gentechnische verfahren
setzen wir beispielsweise in der gentherapie und präimplantationsdiagnostik ein
schon seit jahren wird das thema doping im leistungssport
diskutiert und nicht zuletzt längst haben sportler bei den paralympics künstliche körperteile
oft sind sie mit solchen prothesen schneller als ihre konkurrentinnen und die frage steht im raum ist das sportlich fair
vielleicht erinnert ihr euch an oscar pistorius der 2008 vom internationalen
sportgerichtshof das recht bekam bei den regulären olympischen spielen mitzulaufen mit prothesen aber auch in unseren körpern gibt es
implantate mittlerweile auch elektronisch die daten an den behandelnden arzt oder die ärztin
Senden vor allem bei herz und hirn schrittmachern
ist das gängige praxis und auch hier gibt es sowohl vor als auch nachteile der datenschutz der hier bedroht sein könnte steht einem
notfall gegenüber bei dem ein
automatischer notruf der implantate
leben retten kann oder
hier auch bei der apple wort stehe auch sehr eng mit dem körper verbunden ist noch wird hier der notruf von hand ausgelöst aber
durch human enhancement
werden wir menschen längst nicht nur gesünder und schneller sondern auch stressresistenter
stichwort ritalin oder modafinil
medikamente deren einsatz medizinisch nicht notwendig ist uns aber im arbeitsalltag
leistungsfähiger machen soll auch das menschliche erbgut können wir optimieren wir berichten ja immer öfter mal darüber die präimplantationsdiagnostik
also die diagnostik bevor ein befruchtetes
Menschliches auge implantiert wird dies immer wieder auch thema in bundestagsdebatten die große frage hier in wie weit ist die anwendung
therapeutisch wann wird diese technologie wohl genutzt um ein
wunsch baby zu produzieren was genau die genetischen anlagen hat die sich die eltern vorstellen bei den techniken aus dem bereich human
Enhancement steht die therapie im hintergrund es geht wie gesagt um eine verbesserung oder
optimierung der menschen das ist der fall wenn durch die technik dinge möglich werden die die fähigkeiten der menschen
allein übersteigt deutlich wird das am beispiel
des hörgeräts bei einem patienten einer patientin die
wegen eines unfalls oder einer krankheit durch ein solches gerät wieder normal hören kann handelt sich ganz
eindeutig um eine therapie wenn das gehör gerät aber es möglich macht
frequenzen zu hören die wir menschen normalerweise nicht hören dann ist das ein klarer fall von human enhancement aber sind wir deswegen
deswegen auch gleich dann cyborgs es gibt experten die
überzeugt davon sind dass wir alle heutzutage mehr oder weniger bereits echtes iboxx sind demnach sind wir alle
unfassbar eng verbunden mit technischen geräten smartphones das internet und andere kommunikationsmöglichkeiten
halten wissen für uns bereit dass wir niemals in unserem kopf speichern könnten und tatsächlich haben manche fitness armbänder
augmented reality oder smart watch ist tatsächlich die funktion wie implantate
In früheren science fiction film ich hatte ja gerade schon
erwähnt fest steht nicht nur militär labore und forschungsteams entwickeln neue techniken in diesem bereich auch im
privaten bereich
implantieren sich bio hacker
magnete oder
funk chips mit denen sie dann persönliche daten speichern können oder eben ihre haustür öffnen ganz ohne einen schlüssel und
die anhänger der trans humanistischen vorstellung der evolution
glauben an ein eine extreme zukunft der menschen demnach werden wir uns mit technischen anwendungen auch abseits der
biologischen evolution
weiterentwickeln
zukünftig wird es eine neue
spezies jenseits des biologischen menschen geben die nicht mehr durch die psyche oder den körper
begrenzt ist dieser theorie nach gibt es drei mögliche visionen zum einen designer babys also ein
genetisch neuer mensch das sogenannte genom editing macht es möglich die anhänger erhoffen sich dass
genmanipulation über generationen menschen entstehen lassen könnten die sich radikal von uns heute unterscheiden die zweite version geht um den
implantierten neuen menschen 2 box nano roboter im menschlichen körper
Könnten die brüder aus mensch und maschine
widerstandsfähig machen viele der menschlichen körperteile wären demnach nicht mehr biologisch und die dritte version der
digitale mensch auch upload genannt diese vision ist ziemlich radikal der demnach wird das bewusstsein des menschen
durch eine vollständige digitalisierung
transformiert der name dieses prozesses
wholetrain
emulation oder auch ab loading das gehirn wird hier also quasi als
austauschbare hardware definiert eine digitale unsterblichkeit
Eingeschlossen denn schließlich kann man von diesem so geschaffenen neuen menschen beliebig viel backups machen wo
klar ist jedenfalls die optimierung oder erweiterung von menschen kann durch verschiedene
forschungsbereiche geschehen und tatsächlich tüfteln teams aus der medizin robotik und informatik genauso wie aus dem bereich ki also
künstliche intelligenz an neue chancen umgekehrt dagegen sind noch viele fragen damit
sichergestellt werden kann dass die menschenwürde nicht verletzt wird schwierig würde es auch wenn manipulierte und
instrumentalisierte körper oder auch
geist zu einer unhinterfragt normwert moralische und ethische
diskussionen sind also genauso wie rechtliche rahmenbedingungen unabdingbar
Ja wenn ihr als erstes neues zum thema human enhancement und k erfahren wollt dann endet meine telefonnummer hierbei whatsapp
dann erfahrt ihr vor allen an von neuen videos also bevor sie online gehen garantiert und zur begrüßung
gibt es ein kleines goodie einfach hier draufklicken
und nicht das aber natürlich mit der genau glocke vergessen hier geht es weiter dafür auch draufklicken
unvorstellbar kopf soll auf 9 körper transportiert werden auch in absolutes thema also ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran